die ganze Welt redet über die
ukrainische Gegenoffensive was diese
Offensive für die eigenen Soldaten
bedeutet wird in diesem Krankenhaus in
Frontnähe deutlich
bild-vize Paul Ronzheimer kann mit dem
Soldaten Dima über das sprechen was er
bei der Offensive in den vergangenen
Tagen erlebt hat
[Musik]
Dima kannst du uns erzählen was mit dir
auf dem Schlachtfeld passiert ist und
wie ist die Situation vor Ort ich wurde
von russischer Artillerie oder einem
Panzer Beschuss verletzt genau weiß ich
das nicht ich habe meinen Job erledigt
wurde beschossen und vom Schlachtfeld
evakuiert
werden
du warst also ein Teil der Gegend
Offensive wie lief das in den ersten
Tagen
es ist ein sehr schwieriger und harter
Kampf gegen die Russen die ukrainische
Armee kämpft gut aber die Russen wollen
die Linien verteidigen wir versuchen
diese Linien zu durchbrechen und ich bin
sicher dass wir gewinnen werden
kannst du uns mehr erzählen über die
ersten Tage in saporicia
da gibt es viel Technik viele Maschinen
Panzer Artillerie viele Soldaten alles
gute Kämpfer dann ging es los Panzer
gegen Artillerie
es gab Berichte dass es in den ersten
Tagen sehr schwierig war für die
ukrainische Armee vorzurücken kannst du
das beschreiben
ich bin nur ein einfacher Soldat ich
kann nur das berichten was ich mit
eigenen Augen gesehen habe ich sehe
nicht die großen Hintergründe und
Strategien ich weiß nur dass unsere
Armee und unsere Regierung alles tut in
dem Krieg zu beenden und ukrainische
Gebiete zu befreien
wie bist du verwundert worden und wie
viele deiner Kameraden sind verwundet
oder sogar getötet worden
drei meiner Kameraden starben auf der
Stelle bei dem Angriff ich und ein
weiterer Freund wohin verletzt ich habe
ihn gestern angerufen er hat starke
Schmerzen aber er wird es überleben ich
will zu Armee zurückkehren wenn ich
wieder gesund bin
warst du in der gleichen Einheit wie die
drei Kameraden die gestorben sind
ja ich war nur fünf bis sieben Meter
entfernt von ihnen als es passierte
zuvor people in Germany wars für die
Menschen in Deutschland ist der Krieg
weit weg du bist ein Soldat hier wie
würdest du den Krieg für die deutschen
beschreibend
Krieg ist die Hölle heute sprichst du
noch mit deinen Freunden und lachst und
spielst Karten oder sowas und 20 Minuten
später Boom und sie sterben vor deinen
Augen es ist schrecklich Krieg ist die
Hölle
woran erinnerst du dich bei deiner
Verwundung
Schmerzen ich habe versucht zu verstehen
was da passiert ist und sei nur das Blut
an meinem Knie dann haben meine
Kameraden mich unter Beschuss sofort
evakuiert und ich bin im Krankenhaus
gelandet jetzt bin ich meinen Freund
sehr dankbar dass ich noch lebe
du wurdest vor zwei Tagen verwundet was
hörst du aktuell von der Front
es gibt da kein Internet oder Handys so
ist Krieg nur einmal ich hoffe einfach
dass es meinen Kameraden gut geht und
dass sie alle noch leben
könntest du mit deiner Mutter oder
Freundin sprechen
ja sie versuchen mich aufzumuntern wir
werden bis zum Ende kämpfen und eines
Tages werden wir siegen es gibt keinen
anderen Weg
wie ist das für dich viele Kameraden
haben Gliedmaßen verloren und du sagst
trotzdem du willst zurück auf das
Schlachtfeld
es gibt keinen anderen Weg ich muss das
tun sieh Dich draußen um Russland ist
ein Terrorstaat sie töten Kinder Mütter
das ist furchtbar wir müssen sie
aufhalten ich bin ein normaler Mann ich
will keinen Krieg aber wir müssen
kämpfen um unser Leben für unsere Kinder
Mütter Väter und Freunde
was ist genau mit deinem Bein passiert
und wann wirst du an die Front
zurückkommen
in drei bis sechs Monaten kann ich
zurück ich bin von einem Schrapnell
verletzt worden ich kann dir die
Röntgenaufnahmen zeigen
[Musik]
was hast du vor dem Krieg gemacht ich
war am Finanzmarkt tätig und habe nie
ein Krieg gedacht aber die Russen haben
meine Meinung geändert
hast du deutsche Leopard-Kampfpanzer an
der Front gesehen
ja und wir sind alle sehr dankbar für
die Hilfe militärische und medizinische
Hilfe
deutsche Panzer abgeschossen wurden hast
du was gesehen
es ist Krieg das ist normal wenn es
tausend Panzer gibt werden auch mal zwei
bis drei abgeschossen das ist normal so
ist Krieg
was denkst du über deutsche Leopard
Panzer ich kenne mich mit Panzer nicht
aus aber ich glaube es ist eine tolle
Maschine und besser als russische Panzer
ich denke das deutsche Panzer und
Maschinen uns dabei helfen zu sehen
viele Menschen in Deutschland sagen so
kann es nicht weitergehen dass so viele
junge Menschen sterben was sagst du denn
das ist unsere Realität das ist unser
Leben sicher nicht unsere
Wunschvorstellung wir wollen zu Hause
sein bei unseren Frauen und Kindern
nicht verwundet im Krankenhaus liegen
ich will Fußball spielen Bier trinken
und Bücher lesen aber jetzt müssen wir
für unsere Zukunft kämpfen die
europäische Zukunft wir müssen die
Russen hier stoppen nicht in Polen oder
Deutschland ansonsten werden die Russen
Europa über Rennen
stoping
in your grain not in Germany